And now 99% invisible. I'm Roman Morris. And now the shipping forecast issued by the Met Office on behalf of the Maritime and Coast Guide Agency at 0015 on Monday the 21st of September. Four times every day on radio is all across the British Isles. A BBC announcer begins reading from a seemingly indecisurable script. Viking North-Azeria, southwestally, 527, occasionally gale 8, reinal showers, moderate or good, occasionally poor. This cryptic mesmerizing mumbo jumbo is the shipping forecast, the UK's nautical weather report. Time, doggar, Fisher. Southwest, 405, increasing 5 or 6, occasionally 7 later, occasional rain, moderate, or good. And that voice you hear reading it is Peter Jefferson.
现在是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。现在播报由英国气象局代表海事与海岸警卫署于9月21日星期一0015发布的航运预报。英国群岛各地的广播电台每天四次播送。BBC播音员开始朗读一份看似无法破译的稿件。维京、北乌齐拉，西南风，5到7级，偶有8级大风，阵雨，能见度中等或良好，偶尔较差。这段神秘而令人着迷的胡言乱语就是航运预报，即英国的航海天气报告。泰恩、多格、费舍尔。西南风，4到5级，随后增至5或6级，偶尔7级，偶有降雨，能见度中等或良好。你听到的朗读声音是彼得·杰斐逊。
Yes, hello, I'm Peter Jefferson. I used to work for the BBC for about a lifetime and a half. And one of the things I did there was to read the shipping forecast. Peter started working for the BBC back in the 60s. He was an announcer, which meant he read the news. But one day they handed him a very different sort of script. It was the shipping forecast. Well, that had it since I was a small boy. I never thought that one day I'd be reading it. And when I was faced with it and nobody told me how I should go about reading it, I was somewhat nervous. So he just me how I should go about reading it, I was somewhat nervous.
是的，你好，我是彼得·杰斐逊。我曾在BBC工作了大约一个半辈子。我在那里做的事情之一就是朗读航运预报。彼得从60年代就开始在BBC工作。他是一名播音员，这意味着他负责读新闻。但有一天，他们递给他一份非常不同的稿子。那是航运预报。嗯，我从小就听这个。我从没想过有一天我会读它。当我面对它时，没有人告诉我该怎么读，我感到有些紧张。所以他只是……我该怎么读它，我感到有些紧张。
So he just read the script, word for word. Originally I was reading what's there and wondering to myself what the hell is all this about. But he got through it. And from that day forward Peter Jefferson's job, which he would keep for 40 years until he made a featful mistake, was to read one of the oldest, strangest, most beloved weather forecasts in the world. It's been going for, you know, a hundred years now and it's become a really part of the
所以他只是逐字逐句地读了稿子。起初我只是读着上面的内容，心里纳闷这到底是什么意思。但他坚持了下来。从那天起，彼得·杰斐逊的工作——他一直保持了40年，直到他犯了一个致命的错误——就是朗读世界上最古老、最奇怪、最受喜爱的天气预报之一。它已经持续了，你知道，一百年了，它已经真正成为了
culture here and it's a much loved institution. People regard it as poetry. This is Charlie Connolly. My name's Charlie Connolly. I'm a writer and occasional radio presenter and I've written a number of travel books including attentional shipping, a journey around the shipping forecast. Charlie is pretty into the shipping forecast. I've no direct connection to the sea yet, I've got this lifelong love for the shipping forecast and I'm
这里的文化，是一个备受推崇的机构。人们视其为诗歌。这是查理·康诺利。我叫查理·康诺利。我是一名作家和偶尔的电台主持人，我写过几本旅游书，包括《注意所有航运：环绕航运预报的旅程》。查理非常迷恋航运预报。我与海洋没有直接联系，但我对航运预报有着终身的喜爱，而且我
kind of embarrassed to be saying this but I have my alarm set every morning to go off at 20 plus five in time for that early morning shipping forecast. OK, Charlie is really into the shipping forecast. I'm quite obsessed. The story of how Charlie's favorite radio program came to be begins in the 1850s with a man named Fitzroy. It goes back to Admiral Robert Fitzroy who was the captain of the Beagle Charles Darwin ship. After a long, tumultuous, sometimes controversial career that took him all over the world, Bob Fitzroy decided he wanted to find a solution to one of the most serious problems facing sailors in the 19th century.
说这话有点尴尬，但我每天早上都定好闹钟，在5点20分准时起床，为了收听清晨的航运预报。好的，查理真的很迷航运预报。我相当痴迷。查理最喜欢的广播节目的故事始于19世纪50年代，主角是一个叫菲茨罗伊的人。这要追溯到罗伯特·菲茨罗伊海军上将，他是查尔斯·达尔文乘坐的“小猎犬号”的船长。在经历了漫长、动荡、有时充满争议的职业生涯并走遍世界各地后，鲍勃·菲茨罗伊决定寻找解决19世纪水手面临的最严重问题之一的方法。
The weather. By the mid-19th century, the amount of shipping around the world was absolutely phenomenal. There were ships crossing the oceans all the time and huge storms were blow up at sea and ships would be lost, lives would be lost, cargo would be lost. Around this time people were just beginning to understand the connection between air pressure and storms and Fitzroy got really interested in this because of the potential applications for maritime work. Fitzroy was appointed head of the new meteorological office, and he poured all his energy into the study of air pressure. He had a barometer, and he would use it to try to figure out what the weather was about to do. And then one day, in 1859, a ship called the Royal Charter was sailing from Australia to Liverpool.
天气。到19世纪中叶，全球航运量非常惊人。船只一直在穿越大洋，海上会突然刮起巨大的风暴，导致船只失踪、生命丧生、货物损失。大约在这个时候，人们才刚刚开始了解气压与风暴之间的联系，菲茨罗伊因为其在海事工作中的潜在应用而对此产生了浓厚兴趣。菲茨罗伊被任命为新气象办公室的负责人，他将全部精力投入到气压研究中。他有一个气压计，他会用它来试图弄清楚天气即将发生什么变化。然后有一天，在1859年，一艘名为“皇家宪章号”的船正从澳大利亚航行到利物浦。
Many of the passengers on board were miners returning from the Australian Goldfields. They were almost home when suddenly. A huge storm blew up in the RSC and chased the ship up the coast. Robert Fitzroy was sitting in his house in London at the time. And he saw his barometer on the wall at home. He saw it suddenly drop dramatically. So he knew there was a big storm somewhere
船上的许多乘客是从澳大利亚金矿回来的矿工。他们快到家时，突然。爱尔兰海刮起了一场巨大的风暴，追赶着船只沿海岸航行。罗伯特·菲茨罗伊当时正坐在伦敦的家中。他看到了墙上的气压计。他看到气压突然急剧下降。所以他知道某个地方有一场大风暴
in the vicinity of Britain and Ireland. The captain of the royal charter tried to write out the storm, but eventually the winds blew the ship onto the rocks. The royal charter sunk and over 450 people drowned. Where old Fitzroy took this really badly because he kind of felt responsible almost for this terrible disaster that he couldn't warn anyone. Fitzroy decided to devote the rest of his life to saving lives at sea by predicting the
在英国和爱尔兰附近。皇家宪章号的船长试图在风暴中航行，但最终风将船吹到了岩石上。皇家宪章号沉没了，450多人溺水身亡。老菲茨罗伊对此感到非常难过，因为他觉得自己对这场可怕的灾难负有责任，因为他没能警告任何人。菲茨罗伊决定余生致力于通过预测天气来拯救海上生命。
weather. Which, in Victorian times, was pretty controversial because they were very religious people and anything that kind of sounded a bit like prophecy, was kind of hereby dragons and witchcraft as far as the Victorians were concerned. So he decided to use a synonym for prophecy that didn't sound quite so witchy. He invented, as I say, invented the term weather forecast
这在维多利亚时代是相当有争议的，因为他们是非常虔诚的人，任何听起来有点像预言的东西，在维多利亚人看来都被视为龙和巫术。所以他决定使用一个听起来不那么像巫术的预言同义词。正如我所说，他发明了“天气预报”这个词
to distinguish it from prophecy and superstition and all that kind of thing. Fitzroy, inventor of the weather forecast, delivered his prognostications by telegraph to the various ports around the UK. Signal flags were hoisted in the harbor to warn ships heading out to sea. Eventually his forecasts were published in the newspaper, and while they were often ridiculed by readers at the time, they were pretty accurate, and they became indispensable for sailors in Fischerman.
以将其与预言、迷信等区分开来。天气预报的发明者菲茨罗伊通过电报将他的预测发送到英国各地的港口。港口升起信号旗，警告出海的船只。最终，他的预报在报纸上发表，虽然当时经常受到读者的嘲笑，但它们相当准确，并成为水手和渔民不可或缺的工具。
I mean, it's impossible to calculate the number of lives that were saved as a result of Fitzroy and his work. And decades after his death, Fitzroy's shipping forecast would expand its reach and become a British-spoken word love poem to the sea. All thanks to a new technology. Radio. The BBC. This is Toyota, the first shipping forecast went out on
我的意思是，无法计算因菲茨罗伊及其工作而获救的生命数量。在他去世几十年后，菲茨罗伊的航运预报扩大了影响范围，成为了一首英国口语化的海洋情诗。这一切都归功于一项新技术。广播。BBC。这是丰田，第一次航运预报是在
the airwaves. The BBC radio full. Now, the shipping forecast is she by the metaphors. There have been many shipping forecast readers over the years. Viking, North Achara, South Achara. Easterly or Southeastly becoming cyclonic five to seven squally shars, moderate or good. In 1969, Peter Jefferson joined the club. When he first started, he didn't understand the words
广播中播出的。BBC广播全集。现在，航运预报由气象局发布。多年来，有很多航运预报员。维京、北乌齐拉、南乌齐拉。偏东风或东南风，转为气旋风，5到7级，阵雨，能见度中等或良好。1969年，彼得·杰斐逊加入了这个行列。他刚开始时，并不理解他读的词
he was reading. He was not a sailor. In fact, he couldn't even swim. He didn't know the difference between a gale and a cyclone. He didn't know exactly where doggar was. So somebody took me to one side and said, well, it doesn't sound as though you're quite across this, so this is what it means. Peter learned that the numbers are wind speeds.
他不是水手。事实上，他甚至不会游泳。他不知道大风和气旋的区别。他不知道多格在哪里。所以有人把我拉到一边说，听起来你不太了解这个，所以这就是它的意思。彼得了解到数字是风速。
The directions are wind directions, and the random adjectives like good or poor are descriptions of the visibility. And all those whimsical names are real places, regions of the ocean around Great Britain named by the Met Office. Some are named after islands or towns along the coast. Some are named after rivers. Some are named after sand banks.
方向是风向，而像“良好”或“较差”这样的随机形容词是对能见度的描述。所有那些异想天开的名字都是真实的地方，是英国周围由气象局命名的海洋区域。有些是以岛屿或沿海城镇命名的。有些是以河流命名的。有些是以沙洲命名的。
There's one called Rockall, which literally is a rock sticking out of the sea, inhabited by sea girls, nothing else, I think. Sailors know how to decode the shipping forecast, and over the years it has provided them with really important information. But most people in Great Britain are landlubbers. They do not need to know the weather conditions around some sea-girl rock hundreds of miles from the nearest coastline.
有一个叫罗科尔的地方，它实际上是一块突出海面的岩石，除了海鸥，我想什么都没有。水手们知道如何解读航运预报，多年来，它为他们提供了非常重要的信息。但英国的大多数人都是旱鸭子。他们不需要知道离最近海岸几百英里外的一块海鸥岩石周围的天气状况。
Still, there's just something about the forecast that appeals to them. Many people find the words and the, I suppose, the tone and the pace, quite mesmerizing in a way. People have described it as everything from just very soothing to a sort of prayer. And maybe you can see where this is heading. Maybe as you listen to Peter, your eyelids are getting heavy, and your thoughts are getting dreamy. If this is the case, you are not alone. Peter discovered pretty early on that people all across Great Britain were tuning into the
尽管如此，预报中还是有一些东西吸引着他们。许多人发现这些词，以及，我想，语调和节奏，在某种程度上非常迷人。人们将其描述为从非常舒缓到某种祈祷的一切。也许你能看出这是什么意思。也许当你听彼得朗读时，你的眼皮变得沉重，你的思绪变得梦幻。如果是这样，你并不孤单。彼得很早就发现，全英国的人都在收听
late night shipping forecast just before 1 o'clock in the morning, for something entirely different from its intended purpose. Somebody once said to me, we love listening to you sending me a sleep at late at night. Peter was lulling them into sweet, sweet oblivion. I took this little backhanded compliment really in a way. For the record, I hear this a lot too. You have told me that my voice puts you to sleep. It doesn't bother me. I'm sure you wake up in the morning and listen to every episode from the beginning and
深夜1点前后的航运预报，其目的与初衷完全不同。有人曾经对我说，我们喜欢听你深夜送我入睡。彼得让他们陷入了甜蜜的遗忘。我把这个小小的反讽赞美当作一种恭维。顺便说一句，我也经常听到这个。你们告诉我我的声音让你们入睡。这并不困扰我。我相信你们早上醒来会从头开始听每一集，并且
really appreciate the craftsmanship and the quality journalism. You know, if one sort of cuts oneself off from the actual meaning, it doesn't actually have that time have a meaning to you. Then it's just a, I hope, pleasant voice, speaking to you in a soothing way. On YouTube, someone shrung dozens of shipping forecasts together into a five hour video. And in the comments, there are all these people going on and on about how much the shipping
真正欣赏其中的工艺和高质量的新闻报道。你知道，如果一个人切断了实际含义，它实际上对你来说就没有意义了。那么它只是一个，我希望，悦耳的声音，以舒缓的方式对你说话。在YouTube上，有人将几十个航运预报串联成一个五小时的视频。在评论区，有很多人不停地说航运预报是如何治愈他们的失眠的。我几乎每天晚上都听着这个入睡。它有一种奇怪的舒缓感。是的，它也让我无聊得睡着了。你们。有几十条这样的评论。喜欢这个。太无聊了。
forecast has helped cure their insomnia. I fall asleep to this almost every night. There's something oddly soothing about it. Yep, boars the pants off me to sleep as well. Y'all. There's dozens of these comments. Love this. So boring.
睡前故事。ZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZ 但如今，许多水手船上都有天气雷达和可以上网的智能手机。我很惊讶它竟然还在，因为现在有很多其他方式可以获取这些信息，而不是听广播。然而，几十年过去了，BBC仍然每天在完全相同的时间广播预报。几年前，他们改变了航运预报的播出时间，伦敦广播大厦外有成千上万的人游行抗议。这可能有点夸张，但重点是英国人热爱航运预报，你不应该试图把它从他们身边夺走。所以天知道如果它真的发生会怎样，那将是一场内战。
Bedtime story. ZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZ But these days, many sailors have weather radar on board and smartphones with internet access. I'm surprised actually that it's still there because there are many other ways of now getting that information rather than listening to the radio. And yet decade after decade, the BBC continues to broadcast the forecast every single day at the exact same time. Some years ago now they changed the time the shipping forecast went out and there were literally thousands of people marching on broadcasting house in London. This might be a bit of an exaggeration but the point is the British love the shipping forecast and you shouldn't try to take it away from them. So goodness knows what might happen that it will be a civil be civil war-resting.
在几十年的职业生涯中，彼得·杰斐逊成为了航运预报最知名的播音员之一，他的声音是水手和失眠者共同的节拍器。彼得在BBC还有各种其他职责，但他从未真正摆脱与预报的联系，甚至在他自己的婚礼上也是如此。我和我当时的未婚妻在教堂外，我们在进去之前听到里面传来了巨大的笑声，我们想，到底发生了什么？牧师在里面发表了他所谓的“婚礼预报”，他将他们的伴侣关系描述为“中等，转为良好”。这引起了极大的笑声，
Over his decades-long career, Peter Jefferson became one of the most recognizable readers of the shipping forecast, and his voice was a metronome for sailors and insomniacs alike. Peter had all kinds of other responsibilities at the BBC, but he could never really escape his association with the forecast, not even at his own wedding. And my then future wife and myself were outside the church and we had these great gaffors of laughter going on inside before we went in and we thought, what Earth is going on? The vicar was in there delivering what he called their wedding forecast in which he described their partnership as moderate, becoming good. Which caused a great deal of laughter,
当我们听到时，我们觉得太棒了。然后有一天，在得知一些坏消息后，彼得犯了一个错误。那天早些时候，我被告知我得了前列腺癌，老实说，我不认为我那天应该去上班，因为我的心思不在我实际做的事情上。正如你可以想象的那样，它在其他事情上。他在过渡时结巴了。
and when we heard it, we thought it was fantastic. And then one day, after learning some bad news, Peter made a mistake. Earlier that day I'd been told I'd got prostate cancer and quite honestly I didn't think I should have gone into work that day because my mind was not on what I was actually doing. It was on other things as you can probably imagine. He stumbled over his words during the transition.
我以为我关了麦克风，但我没有，我说，哦，该死。不幸的是，它播出了。不久之后我被解雇了。我接到老板打来的电话，说他们会履行我未来几周的轮班，但之后，谢谢，再见。BBC一直坚持说他们解雇彼得不是因为这个失误。他已经在那里工作了很长时间，他们想在楼里引入一些新面孔。有趣的是，我的意思是，无论如何，几个月后我也在考虑停止工作。
I thought I closed the mic, but I hadn't, and I said, oh fuck. And unfortunately it went out. And I followed it shortly afterwards. Peter was fired. I got a phone call at home from my boss saying that they would honor that the shifts I'd got over the next few weeks, but after that, thank you and goodbye. The BBC has consistently maintained that they didn't fire Peter because of this slip-up. He had been around for a long time and they wanted to get some fresh faces in the building. Funnily enough, I mean, I was thinking of stopping on a few months later anyway.
不过，预报必须继续，而且确实如此。我认为每天四次播出的航运预报在警告人们恶劣天气方面非常重要，也提醒人们我们是一个海洋民族，我们是一个海洋国家。这是查理·康诺利。他谈论航运预报就像它是文学作品一样
The forecast must go on though, and it does. The shipping forecast going out four times a day, I think, is terrifically important in terms of warning people of bad weather and just reminding people that we're a maritime people, we're a maritime nation. This is Charlie Connelly again. He talks about the shipping forecast like it's a piece of literature
以及对英国与海洋关系的颂歌。我们有像《坎特伯雷故事集》和《贝奥武夫》这样的民族史诗，我会认为航运预报是英国现代民族史诗的等价物。一部每天更新章节的民族史诗，每天四次，由某个办公楼里的一群气象学家编写。由这些坐在办公桌前的人，你知道，旁边放着废纸篓，里面有褐色的苹果核，你知道，他们的妻子给他们发短信说，什么时候回家，而他们正在制作这些神奇的东西。就是它。我听到了，每一个。至于我们的英雄彼得·杰斐逊，被解雇并没有切断他与航运预报的联系。
and owed to Great Britain's relationship with the sea. We've got national epics like the Canterbury Tales and Bear Wolf and I would argue for the shipping forecast to be the modern equivalent of a British national epic. A national epic with new chapters written every day, four times a day, by a bunch of meteorologists in an office block somewhere. By these guys sitting at desks, you know, with waste paper bins next to them, with browning apple cores in them, and you know, and their wives texting them saying, what's so many be home, and they're producing this amazing stuff. It's it. I hear those, every one of them. As for our hero, Peter Jefferson, getting fired did not sever his connection with the shipping forecast.
如果有的话，它反而加强了这种联系。这让他有时间写了一整本关于它的书，而且他有一个新项目。嗯，那只是去年，对吧？我突然收到了一封电子邮件。这封邮件来自流行的冥想应用程序 Calm。Calm 制作他们所谓的“睡眠故事”，旨在睡前收听，他们想让彼得为他们朗读航运预报。他们只是认为这会成为一个相当舒缓的睡前故事。彼得答应了。他朗读了他在BBC最后一天的预报。
If anything, it made it stronger. It gave him time to write an entire book about it, and he's got a new project. Well, that was just last year, right? I got an email out of the blue. The email was from the Popular Meditation app, Com. Com produces what they call sleep stories, meant to be listened to right before bed, and they wanted Peter to read the shipping forecast for them. They just thought it would make a rather soothing bedtime story. Peter obliged. He read the forecast from his last day at the BBC.
那天相当安静。没有大的风暴。他们要求我读得比我在广播中通常读的要慢得多，但显然在这里它奏效了，而且非常成功。非常成功，以至于他们雇他去读他们的另一个睡前故事。而这个与航运预报无关。他们想让我做的是读这些非常、非常长且非常、非常晦涩的法律文件，他们认为这会让一些人入睡，我认为他们绝对是对的。这里有一点
It was a pretty quiet day, otherwise. No major storms. They asked me to read it much more slowly than I would normally did on on air, but apparently here it worked and it's been very successful. So successful that they hired him to read another of their bedtime stories. And this one has nothing to do with the shipping forecast. What they want me to do is read this very, very long and very, very turgid legaleseese documents which they think will put some people to sleep and I think they're absolutely right. Here's a little
彼得朗读欧盟最近的《通用数据保护条例》的片段。考虑到《欧洲联盟运作条约》，特别是其第16条，这是相当令人昏昏欲睡的内容。考虑到欧盟委员会的提案，考虑到欧洲经济和社会委员会的意见。他可能没有在海上拯救生命，但彼得认为帮助人们入睡是一项非常光荣的职业。作为一个自己也有严重入睡困难的人，
taste of Peter reading from the EU's recent general data protection regulation. Having regards to the treaty of the functioning of the European Union and in particular article 16 thereof, it's pretty sino-winding stuff. Having regard to the proposal from the European Commission, having regard to the opinion of the European Economic and Social Committee. He may not be saving lives at sea, but Peter believes helping people get to sleep is a very honorable profession. As somebody who has huge problems falling asleep himself,
我希望它确实有效，因为我知道如果你无法入睡是一件多么可怕的事情。德国湾，亨伯。西风，西南风，4到5级，起初增至6级，偶有降雨，能见度中等或良好，泰晤士河，多格，怀特。风向不定，转为西南风3或4级，随后增至4或5级，天气主要晴朗，能见度中等或良好。这对你来说够了吗？太棒了。
I hope that it does work, because I know a horrible thing it is if you can't get to sleep. German bite Hummer. West backing, Southwest, 40 5, increasing 6 at first, occasional rain, moderate or good, Thames, Derva, White. Variable, becoming Southwestally 3 or 4, increasing 4 or 5 later, mainly fair, moderate or good. Is that enough for you? That's great.
我本来总是要打断你的，但我被迷住了，我想听完。彼得·杰斐逊的书叫《现在是航运预报》。查理·康诺利的书叫《注意所有航运：环绕航运预报的旅程》。你可以在我们的网站上找到这两本书的链接。网址是 9i9pi.org。你还醒着吗？如果你还醒着，亲爱的听众，请继续收听更多关于用声音让人入睡的艺术。休息之后。好的，所以航运预报意外地成为了许多人的睡前仪式，我们的节目也是如此。
I was just always going to stop you, but then I got mesmerized and I want to finish. Peter Jefferson's book is called, and now the Shipping Forecast. And Charlie Conley's book is called Attention All Shipping, a journey around the shipping forecast. You can find links to both on our website. It's 9i9pi.org. You're still awake. If you are still awake, dear listener, stay tuned for more of the art of putting people to sleep with sound. After the break. Okay, so the shipping forecast became a bedtime ritual for a lot of people accidentally, and the same can be said of our show.
虽然本周的这一集可能有点例外，但大多数时候我们并不是试图让你入睡，但我在这里和德鲁·阿克曼在一起，他是播客《与我同眠》的创作者，他节目的全部目标是帮助人们入睡。是的，所以《与我同眠》是一个给成年人的睡前故事播客，整个想法是让听众
Although this week's episode might be a bit of an exception, most of the time we're not trying to put you to sleep, but I'm here with Drew Ackerman, who is the creator of a podcast called Sleep With Me, and the whole goal of his show is to help people dose off. Yeah, so Sleep With Me is a bedtime story podcast for grownups, and the whole idea is to take the listeners
从让他们清醒的事情中转移注意力，让他们参与进来，足以让他们关注故事或我所说的话，但他们不会感到必须继续听下去的压力，而且还有那种引人入胜的东西即将出现的风险。我可能会展示，我避开引人入胜的部分，进入琐碎的细节，这是我的专长，但这就像一个床边伴侣，旨在陪伴在那里。在听众的脑海中，理想情况下，它足够松散，让他们觉得当他们想的时候，他们可以放开我的手，飘然而去。
mind off of what's keeping them awake, to just engage them enough so they can pay attention to the story or to what I'm saying, but where they don't feel the pressure to keep listening, and there's also the risk of like this compelling thing coming up. I might show, I steer right around the compelling parts and I go into the inane details, this is my kind of specialty, but it's just like a bedside companion that's meant to be there. In the migrip on the listener, ideally, it's just loose enough that they feel like they could just let go of my hand and drift away when they want to.
是的。我想如果你在YouTube上搜索放松视频，会有竖琴音乐或呼呼声或人们耳语之类的东西。这吸引了那种在一天中不停运转的理智的猴子大脑。你创造了一个足够叙事的东西，让人们可以抓住，
Yeah. I think that if you were to look up what relaxation videos on YouTube, there's a harp music or a whooshing sounds or people whispering or something. This appeals to this sort of the intellectual monkey mind that is tripping away at your day. And you create something enough of a narrative that people can latch onto,
但它又足够松散，让人们也可以从中飘离。你是怎么想到用这种方式成为那种类型的睡前伴侣的？是的，嗯，我有这个争议，我相信我不想在播客中提起，但我称大脑的那部分为“大脑机器人”。我相信我的大脑，也许其他人的大脑，被这些小机器人占据了。所有这些机器人，它们都有不同的用途，比如担心过去。
but it's loose enough that people can also drift away from. And how did you come up with this as the way to be that type of bedtime companion? Yeah, well, I have this controversy, I'll believe that I don't want to bring up on the podcast, but I call that kind of part of our brain, brain bots. And I believe that my brain and maybe other people's brains are populated by these little droids. In all of these droids, they have served these different purposes, like worrying thinking about the past.
不幸的是，它们都没有睡眠模式。我发现通过说，嘿，过来这里。让我给你讲个故事。我听说你在担心高中。当你把柠檬水洒在身上时，我给你讲个故事。这就是你担心的关于高中的事情。当你把柠檬水洒在衬衫上时，我会谈论吊带一会儿，特别是彩虹吊带。这个想法是，即使一方会说，等一下，我可以想象彩虹吊带。我有过，我从来没有过，但理想情况下，它就像一些足够视觉化且足够有趣的东西，你会想几分钟，打断你的思路。
And none of them have sleep modes, unfortunately. And I found that by just kind of saying, hey, come on over here. Let me tell you a story. I hear you're worrying about high school. And when you spill that lemonade down, you a story. Here's what you're worrying about high school. And when you spill that lemonade down your shirt, I'm going to talk about suspenders for a little while and rainbow suspenders in particular. And the idea is that even one party is going to be like, wait a second, I could pitch your rainbow suspenders. I've had, I've never had them, but ideally it's like something that's just visual enough and just interesting enough that you'll think about it for a few minutes and interrupt your train of thoughts.
但随后你会想，好吧，已经14分钟了。他还在谈论彩虹吊带。而且，他试图，我能看出他试图对此做一个隐喻。你知道，彩虹吊带下面是什么，所以他们明白了。我们做什么，这里有一个录制这次采访时刚出现的问题。有没有戴彩虹吊带的妖精？因为他们应该有。但我真的想取悦人们，或者让他们感受到某种愉悦，而不是睡前那种感觉如此严肃和不祥。即使我没有达到那个目标，就像我开玩笑地对听众说的那样，我可能不会让你微笑，
But then you'll be like, okay, it's been 14 minutes. He's still talking about rainbow suspenders. And like, he is trying to, I can see him trying to make a metaphor about it. You know, what's somewhere under the rainbow suspender or so they get it. What we do, here's a question that just came up was recording this interview. Are there any leprechauns that have rainbow suspenders? Because they should. But I really want to delight people or make them feel some kind of delight versus bedtime that can feel so serious and ominous. And even if I don't hit that goal, it's like, I joke with listeners like, I might not make you smile,
但也许我可以让你的脸达到中性水平。就是这样。我达到了我的目标。就像通过过度尝试，我可以到达人们不再大笑或傻笑，而是说，哦，是的，是的，那还不错的地方。德鲁的讲故事方法非常独特，但多年来，他尝试过入睡
but maybe I could bring your face to a neutral level. And that's it. I hit my gut. It's like by over trying to overshoot, I can just get to the place where the people, instead of laughing or gofying, they say, oh yeah, yeah, that's pretty good. Drew's approach to storytelling is quite unique, but over the years, he has tried to fall asleep
听各种不同类型的音频。他成长过程中有一个叫《德门托博士》的喜剧广播节目，他喜欢在深夜听它来帮助他入睡。所以当我还是个孩子，睡眠有问题时，我记得我告诉过一个同学，我晚上睡不着，周日晚上是最糟糕的，因为他们开始对学校感到焦虑，
to lots of different types of audio. When he was growing up, there was this comedy radio show called Dr. Demento, and he liked to listen to it late at night to help him get to sleep. So when I was a kid and I had trouble sleeping, I remember I was telling this one classmate, like I can't sleep at night, and Sunday nights are the worst because they start having anxiety about school,
我已经上学几天了。他说，我哥哥听这个广播节目，在周日晚上9点到11点，这是一个喜剧广播节目。他们播放模仿歌曲，我收听了它，我想德门托博士提供了一些我想要的东西。就像这可能是一个被过度使用的词或听起来过于雄心勃勃，但这确实是同情的概念，当你分解这个词时，就像一起受苦。我会带德门托博士知道这一点，但这就像德门托博士和我在一起
and I've been at school a few days. And he said, my older brother listens to this radio show, and it's on Sunday nights from 9 to 11, and it's a comedy radio show. They play parody songs, and I tuned into it, and I guess one of the things I wanted in the doctor, Demento provided. And like this can be like a overused word or sound over ambitious, but like it really is this idea of compassion when you break up the word like suffering with or suffering together. And I'll take Dr. Demento knew that, but it was like Dr. Demento was there with me
坐在我的床边说，嘿，这太糟糕了。你睡不着，我真的为你感到难过。当我睡不着时，我的大脑里有一个关于我自己的故事，关于过去，关于未来。我只想误导人们说，嘿，听听这个故事。这是一个更好的故事。你不是其中的角色。它只是在这里陪伴你。这就是重点，你甚至不需要听它。你甚至不需要入睡。我只是在这里给你讲故事。
sitting by my bedside saying, Hey, this kind of stinks. You can't sleep and I really feel bad for you. And when I can't sleep, I have this story about myself running through my brain, about the past, about the future. And I want to just misdirect people and say, Hey, listen to this story over here. It's a it's a nicer story. You're not a character in it. And it's just here to keep you company. And here's the thing, you don't even need to listen to it. You don't even need to fall asleep. I'll just be here to tell you the story.
是的，我想这也是我小时候想要的。既然你已经做了几年《与我同眠》，你从节目的听众那里得到了什么样的反馈？所以在节目的前八个月，偶尔在最后，我会开玩笑。我想这是因为我刚开始做播客，我真的很害怕，我会开自嘲的玩笑，
And yeah, I guess that's what I wanted as a kid too. Now that you've been doing sleep with me for a few years, what kind of feedback have you gotten from the listeners of the show? So within the first eight months of the show, occasionally at the end, I would make jokes. And I think it was because I was new to podcasting and I was really afraid, I would make self-effacing jokes,
比如，哦，节目进行到这里可能没人听了。我记得我连续收到三封电子邮件，人们说，请不要那样说。就像，我在节目结束时还醒着，我听这个节目是为了分心，因为我不会入睡，被提醒这一点让我很痛苦。
like, oh, no one's probably listening to this at this point in the show. And I remember I got three emails in a row from people saying, please don't say that. Like, I am awake at the end of the show, and I'm listening to the show to be distracted, like, because I'm not gonna fall asleep, and it's painful for me to be reminded of that.
这让我回到了那种记忆，就像我听《德门托博士》时躺在那里，我也没希望入睡。所以这是一个非常有力的反馈。然后就像得到关于人们害怕什么的反馈，然后试图绕过它。比如对于蜘蛛，它可能是基于网的生物，或者对于任何其他可怕的动物。就像被迫的朋友。
And it brought me right back to that memory of, like, lying there when I listened to Dr. Mento, there was no hope of me falling asleep either. So that was one piece of feedback that was pretty powerful. And then it's like just getting feedback about what people are afraid of and then trying to steer around that. Like for spiders, it'd be like web-based beings or for any other animals that are scary. It's like forced friends.
就像那样。就像试着把车绕过那些树，这样你就不会撞上它们。太搞笑了。那是德鲁·阿克曼，播客《与我同眠》的主持人和创作者。无论你在哪里听播客，都可以看看《与我同眠》。《99%隐形》本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，谢里夫·优素福进行混音和技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。
Like stuff like that. Like try to just drive the car right around those trees, so you know, crash into them. That's so funny. That's Drew Ackerman, host and creator of the podcast, Sleep With Me. Check out Sleep With Me, wherever you listen to podcasts. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, Mix and Tech Production by Sharif Yusuf, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
团队的其他成员包括高级编辑吉尼拉尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特鲁布尔曼、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、塔伦·马扎，以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心 Radio Row 制作。《99%隐形》是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在 radiotopia.fm 上找到他们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。
The rest of the team includes senior editor-genilani Hall Avery Troubleman, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
你可以在 Twitter 上关注我 @RomanMars，关注节目 @99PIOrg。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也有账号。但如果你想要一堆其他的 99PI 剧集在你入睡时播放，请访问 99PI.org。现在是航运预报，由气象局代表《99%隐形》发布，时间为 2018 年 7 月 23 日星期一。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want a bunch of other 99PI episodes for you to play as you are drifting off to sleep, go to 99PI.org. And now the shipping forecast issued by the Met Office on behalf of 99% invisible for Monday, 23 July 2018.
未来24小时区域预报。西维京，南风4或5级，随后转为风向不定3级，海况轻微，天气主要晴朗，能见度中等或良好。东维京，北乌齐拉，西南乌齐拉，风向不定3或4级，海况轻微，天气晴朗，能见度良好。东东南乌齐拉，西北风5或6级，转为西风4级，能见度中等，随后转为轻微，天气晴朗，能见度良好。40年代，南维京西南风，3或4级，第四，时间风向不定，主要为南风或西南风，3或4级，有时增至5级，海况轻微，天气晴朗，随后有雨，能见度良好，偶尔较差。多格，南风或西南风，3或4级，海况轻微，天气晴朗，能见度良好。
The area forecast for the next 24 hours. West Viking, southerly 4 or 5, becoming variable 3 later, slight, mainly fair, moderate or good. East Viking, North Atsira, West South Atsira, variable 3 or 4, slight, fair, good. East South at 0, northwestern leaf 5 or 6, backing western leaf 4 later, moderate, becoming slight later, fair, good. 40s, South-Virgin Southwest, 3 or 4arty, Fourth, Time Variable, mainly South or Southwest, 3 or 4, increasing 5 at times, slight, fair, then rain, good, occasionally poor later. Dogger, South or Southwest, 3 or 4, slight, fair, good.
东北费舍尔，西北风5或6级，转为西风4级，能见度中等，随后转为轻微，天气晴朗，能见度良好。泰晤士河，皮埃蒙特，西北风3或4级，有时增至5级，随后有阵雨，能见度良好，偶尔中等。布什罗德，岩脊，北风或西北风4或5级，偶尔6级，海况轻微或中等，有阵雨，起初有雷雨，能见度良好。大湖，北风或西北风4或5级，偶尔6级，海况轻微或中等，天气晴朗，能见度良好。高地公园，格伦维尤，西风或西北风，3或4级，偶尔5级，格伦维尤除外，海况轻微或中等，天气晴朗，随后有雨或阵雨，能见度良好，偶尔中等。埃尔默塞德，风向不定3或4级，转为西南风4或5级，海况轻微，天气晴朗，随后有雨，
Northeast Fisher North-East Fisher North-Western Lee 5 or 6, backing Westerly 4 later, moderate becoming slight later, fair, good. Temescal Piedmont North-West 3 or 4, increasing 5 at times, slight showers later, good occasionally moderate. Bushrod Rock Ridge, North-Ely or Northwest-Ely 4 or 5, occasionally 6, slight or moderate showers, Thundery at first, good. Grand Lake, North or Northwest 4 four or five, occasionally six-later, slight or moderate, fair, good. Highland Park, Glenview, Western or Northwestern, three or four, occasionally five, except in Glenview, slight or moderate, fair, then rain or showers, good occasionally moderate. Elmerced, variable three or four becoming southwest four or five, slight, fair than rain,
能见度良好，偶尔较差。阿拉米达，弗鲁特韦尔，丛林镇，西南风转西北风4或5级，起初偶尔6级，弗鲁特韦尔除外。海况轻微或中等，有雨或毛毛雨，能见度良好，偶尔较差。西奥克兰，西风或西北风4或5级，能见度中等，西部偶尔轻微，随后有雨，天气晴朗，能见度良好。下部，南风4或5级，西部起初偶尔6级，转为风向不定3或4级，
good occasionally poor. Alameda Fruitvale Jingle-Town Southwest Viering Northwest four or five, occasionally six at first except in Fruitvale. Slight or moderate, rain or drizzle, good occasionally poor. West Oakland, west or northwest four or five, moderate occasionally slight later in west, rain then fair, good. Lower bottoms. Sutherly four or five occasionally six at first in west, becoming variable three or four,
海况轻微或中等，偶有降雨，有雾，能见度中等或良好，偶尔非常差。杰克伦敦广场，南风转西北风4或5级，东部起初偶尔6级，随后减弱至3级。能见度中等，转为轻微或中等，有雨或毛毛雨，有雾，能见度中等或良好，偶尔非常差。唐人街，气旋风，主要为北风5或6级，转为风向不定3或4级，海况轻微或中等，起初有雾，能见度中等或良好，起初偶尔非常差。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心，风向不定1或2级，早晨有雾，随后天气晴朗，能见度良好，转为海利古德。
slight or moderate, occasional rain, fog patches, moderate or good, occasionally very poor. Jack London Square Sutherly varying north-westernly four or five, occasionally six at first in east, then decreasing three for a time. Moderate becoming slight or moderate, rain or drizzle, fog patches, moderate or good, occasionally very poor. Chinatown Cyclonic mainly-northily five or six, becoming variable three or four, slight or moderate, fog patches at first, moderate or good, occasionally very poor at first. Beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California, variable one or two, fog early, then fair, good, becoming Heligud.
Radio Tapio。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radio Tapio。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。